- I know that many of you
would love to become more productive.
And this certainly applies to me as well.
But how can you accomplish that?
One person from the audience
a couple of weeks ago
sent me a list from a
service called Filtered
where they analyzed about
100 productivity hacks
and made a ranking out of it.
So welcome to a new coffee
break here on my channel.
In this video,
I will look into the top
10 productivity hacks.
And I will give you my view
whether these are really effective or not.
In the past,
I was sometimes a bit skeptical
about these productivity tips.
I made a video about
this in the past as well,
linking it somewhere above here,
but in the end of this video,
I will also share one bonus tip,
productivity tip that
really helped me in my life.
So stay tuned and get into it.
The first productivity
tip I want to talk about
is time boxing.
Time boxing means that
you look at your calendar,
you plan your week or your month ahead,
and you schedule some
time into your calendar
for things that you really
would like to accomplish.
And I feel like this
is especially effective
for things that are outside
of your regular work.
Of course, in your regular work,
you know that you will
need to make the time
for the things that really matter.
But what is everything
that comes on top of that?
Maybe you have some side projects
that you want to work on.
Maybe you have an exercise routine
that you want to prioritize.
Make sure that you block off
this time in the calendar
and then be realistic.
Do you even have enough time
in the evenings, on the
weekends to get this done?
Make sure to prioritize
accordingly to get this right.
Next step is prioritization.
It is of course essential that at work,
you prioritize your
tasks in the right way.
So let me share three tips here.
These are rather rule of thumbs
that I think apply most of the time.
First, focus on things
that need to move to other people's desks.
So if someone else is waiting
for an input from you,
then this person's able
to progress the work
by him or herself, prioritize this.
Make sure you get this through
this other person's desk
as quickly as possible
because then you can also expect
to get the result back rather quickly
while significantly
increasing productivity
of the whole team.
Next, do things first that
lead to some quick wins,
to some quick results.
It's often quite frustrating
if you receive a project,
a task, maybe from your leadership,
and you do some things first
where you know
that only in one or two
or three days of work,
you can actually have something
presentable in your hand.
And of course,
then if your leadership reaches
out to you after one day,
ask what you have done
and you don't really have
anything you can show for,
that's often not ideal.
And third, to prevent burnout,
especially when you're sitting
at your desk in the evening,
it's already getting late,
always ask yourself this
specific piece of work
where you now feel like you
need to work on it right now,
do you really need it for tomorrow?
Is it needed for your workday tomorrow?
And if it's not,
do not work on it in the evening.
Next is the skill of saying no,
especially juniors often feel
like they need to do everything
that someone asks them to do.
This is of course not
really a sustainable way
of looking at your work.
And if you struggle with this,
if you struggle with saying
no in such a work environment,
I created a video in the past
where I also shared specific
tips on this situation.
I will link it above here,
feel free to check it out.
Next productivity tip is
to move during the day.
If you just sit in front of a big screen
from early morning until late evening,
you will very likely get
depressed at some point.
Your energy level just
naturally will go down.
What I implemented for myself
is now since a couple of weeks,
almost every day from Monday
to Friday during lunch break,
I go to the gym.
I signed up for a gym
very close to my office.
And then often I just pick
up something quick to eat
during a video conference
or something like that
so that I do get some food in as well.
I know this is not possible
in every single job,
but even at McKinsey during
my time in consulting
I was able to at least go for short walk,
maybe outside of your client's building,
outside of your home.
This does make a big difference
just to get some fresh air
because otherwise there might be days
where I don't even see the sun.
If in the early morning,
you go into the office,
and then afterwards,
you come back from the office,
the sun has already gone down,
that's of course not really
great environment to work in.
Next step, control your devices.
We all have experienced the situation,
you receive a new email
and then you open Slack
and you see five unread messages on Slack,
then you look at your phone,
lots of notifications on your phone.
How can you even concentrate
in this environment?
How can you even get anything
done in this situation?
Try to schedule some
time in your calendar,
maybe with time boxing,
where you focus on working on your emails
to make sure that you
really have some time
of uninterrupted work
where you can do some deep work done
without getting interrupted all the time
by these types of things.
If so far you took any
value out of this video,
please destroy the like button
and subscribe for the YouTube algorithm.
This would be much appreciated.
And of course,
if you have additional tips
on productivity to share,
leave me a comment in the comment section.
But now let's continue.
Next productivity tip
is to take short breaks.
This is of course very much
related to the tip to move.
But of course,
if you are the personality that
just sits at his or her desk
and you really struggle
to do something else,
think about other tasks,
incorporate a couple
of these short breaks.
Frankly, in an office environment,
often this would be just a
quick chat with a colleague
and then a coffee break.
In my humble opinion,
most people in these environments
don't really like these types of breaks.
But if you do,
make sure to have the time.
For me, again, a big game
changer was the exercise.
The gym time during the day,
that in itself is of course
a valued break as well.
Next productivity hack
is to have an actively managed to do list,
either on a written sheet
or just one of the many
to do management apps
that you can get on your mobile phone,
on the PC, on Mac and so on.
The main reason why this makes sense
is because it gives you peace of mind.
If you don't write down all your to dos,
first, it's very likely that
you will forget something.
And second, you will always feel stressed
because suddenly some to
dos pop up in your mind
and you don't really know
whether this is something
to do now or maybe later.
You are just afraid of forgetting it.
So whenever you get a new task
that you need to get done,
just dump it in any of these
to do management programs
because then you know for sure
that you will have them all written down,
that you won't forget anything.
And besides that,
maybe that's also personality thing,
but I feel like there's very few things
which are as satisfying
as having a sheet of
paper in front of you,
even also one of these apps,
and being able to just cross
off to dos from that list.
That personally always gives me
a little sense of
accomplishment during the day.
A little sense of self-efficacy.
So if you feel in a similar
way about that, try it out.
Next productivity tip is to eat well.
Trust, we've all had the experience
of having had a very heavy lunch
and then in the afternoon,
just feeling down.
Just feeling like you lack any energy
to get anything productive done
for the next one, two or even three hours.
That's of course not great
and probably also not really healthy.
So avoid heavy lunches,
and also be careful about all the snacks
that you eat during the day.
In some companies and
almost all meeting rooms,
there are baskets of sweets,
of chocolate and so on.
And just so easy to
every in other meeting,
eating a bit of this chocolate.
So try to replace these snacks
with more healthy alternatives.
Next productivity tip
is the two minute rule.
This rule says that whenever
you can get a task done
in two minutes,
do it now.
Don't postpone it to later.
If something can get done in two minutes,
there's really no reason to
not taking action right now.
Don't even bother tracking
it in your to do app.
Just the fact that you've opened your app
or take your piece of
paper with your to dos
and you write it down,
this alone will take
one minute or so, right?
So just get it done right now,
then it's finished and you're fine.
Next step is to control your
social media consumption.
This is a problem that many
people have, me included,
that you just waste far too
much time on all these apps,
Instagram, Facebook, TikTok and so on.
I think in most professional contexts,
it's actually LinkedIn.
LinkedIn now became
this big social network
where you can read all these posts,
watch all these videos.
And the mean thing is that for many jobs,
you actually need LinkedIn.
It's one of the tools that
you need for your job.
Frankly, due to this reason,
I haven't even found a good
way of organizing myself
in this regard.
So if you have any good
tips to share on that,
just leave a comment
in the comment section.
Now, finally, I wanna
share the one bonus advice
that was not even present in this list
that I initially talked about
but that I feel had a quite
significant impact on my life.
So many people are using
actually big headphones,
noise canceling headphones
in your work routine
to just blend out the noise and so on.
But in my humble experience,
there is something that
is far more effective
than all these noise canceling headphones,
and this is proper ear plugs.
Something like I have here in my hand.
I started using these in university,
especially during exams.
So it was always allowed during exams
to plug in earplugs like this.
And I feel like just the fact
alone that I used ear plugs
during most of my exams
helped me to improve my grades
by at least one or two
points on all of these exams.
At least for me personally,
this was such a game changer
in how well I was able to concentrate.
And even today,
whenever I want to have
focused quality work time
of one hour, two hours or so,
I just wanna sit in front of
my desk to get something done,
there's nothing else that
helps me as much to concentrate
as proper earplugs.
Again, if you found this helpful,
please leave a like.
I would very much appreciate that.
Big, big, thanks to all
the members of the channel
for supporting the work
here at Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich,
I release weekly videos
here on the channel.
See you again next week,
under then and bye-bye.